[موسيقى]
نعومه
فلا يمكنك منافسه الصين
لكن تايوانيين لا يريدون ان تستولي الصين
على بلادهم بالقوه
حيوان
في تبوء مركز الصداره في تصنيع اشباه
الموصلات تركزت فيها نسبه مهمه من سلسله
التوريد العالميه
في الصين
[موسيقى]
في ذلك مفهوم الجديده لاستخدام
التكنولوجيا والاقتصاد واعتماد الدول على
بعضها البعض وسيله لحمايه امنها
[موسيقى]
23 مليون
وحجم الادخار الحكوميه فيها
549 مليار دولار
صادراتها بلغت 444 مليار دولار سنه 2021
وهي جزيره صغيره يفوق انتاجها ما تنتجه
دول كبيره من خلال الابداع والعمل
حركه الاموال والافكار والتكنولوجيا تتدفق
عبر تايوان تشتهر جزيره التايوان
للالكترونيات الدقيقه
وتصنع خامسه انتاج العالم من اشباه
الموصلات التي تمكن الاجهزه الالكترونيه
والانترنت من العمل اكبر شركاء تايوان
التجاريين ومحرك نبوي الاقتصادي هو البر
الرئيسي الصيني
[تصفيق]
تصنع التايون والصين معا اكثر من نصف
الالكترونيات على سطح الكوكب التي تحرك
الاقتصاد العالمي الهائل
تؤكد بيجي ان تايوان اقليم من اقاليم
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه غالبيه الدول بما
فيها الولايات المتحده رضخت لذلك الضغط
ولم تعد تعترف بتايوان كبلد مستقل
كما تعترض الصين سبيل الانضمام التايوان
المتحده ومنظمه الصحه العالميه اندلع
التوترات في المضيق لكن لم تتطور الى نزاع
مسلح
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد تجنب وقوع اشتباكات الى دهاء
الشاشه او الدبلوماسيين اوحشت الاسلحه بل
الى قطعه دقيقه من السيليكون تحتوي على
الكثير من الاسلاك الادق شبه الموصل
الرقائق الدقيقه اجهزه عجيبه في تعقيدها
حيث يحتوي بعضها على اميال من الاسلاك
داخل قطعه السيليكون الصغيره فيها يتطلب
صنع الرقائق الدقيقه دقه فائقه وخطوات
تتجاوز حدود العمليات المالوفه
ويعمل تقلب السوق العالميه وتطور التقنيه
على تغيير التصاميم باستمرار فالرقائق
الدقيقه التي تمضي فرق المهندسين عاما في
ابتكارها سرعان ما تصبح متجاوزه بعيده
اسابيع من تصنيعها
تحولت تايوان الى حلقه حيويه في سلسله
اشباه الموصلات في العالم منشئه بذلك درعا
واقيا حول الجزيره درعا من السلكون
[موسيقى]
سلك الشيعه
لكنه فعال فتيوان والصين لا يتعاونان فقط
في مجال التصنيع لكن ايضا في قطاع
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه وتكنولوجيا
المعلومات
الذكي الذي يدخل في تركيب الاجهزه التي
تنتجها الصين ثم تشحنها الى مختلفه بقاع
العالم واكبر سوق لها هي الولايات المتحده
وهذا مثلث دورانه
تكنولوجيا المعلومات في العالم
ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث اذا ما عملت الصين
الى مهاجمه تايوان فتعطلت سلسله توريد
اشباه الموصلات واجزاء التركيب الحيويه
الاخرى
[موسيقى]
الكافرون عن علاقه تايوان بالصين
وبالسلسله التوريد الاقتصاديه في العالم
[موسيقى]
يه الثانيه ودمار اوروبا واقتصاداتها بدات
تقدم مستحيلا بسبب الارتياب وانعدام الثقه
الشديدين بين الدول المتجاوره خرج بعض
كبار الساسه المحنكين بخطه طوارئ الفحم
والفولات موردات وطنيان كان حيويين لارساء
قواعد المستقبل
تم توحيد قطاعين الفحم والفولاذ في
البلدان الاوروبيه الكبرى وسرعان ما اصبحت
تعتمد على بعضها البعض في تحقيق انماء
الاقتصادي وقد قال روبرت شومان مبتدع
الخطه لم يعد نشوب حرب بين فرنسا والمانيا
غير وارد وحسب بل غدا مستحيل
لاننا اذا ما اتخذنا هذه الخطوات المحدده
التي تربط بين الفحم والفولاذ والتي تربط
على الاخص بين الفولاذ وصناعه الاسلحه
فيمكننا ان نجعل الحرب مستحيله وغيره
لقد حققت خطه شوم النجاح باهرا اذت الى
قيام الاتحاد الاوروبي ورغم الارتباط
الاقتصادي فان الحواجز السياسيه بما فيها
استمرار التهديد الصيني باستعمال القوه ضد
الجزيره تحول دون قيام اتحاد على غرار
الاتحاد الاوروبي في المدى المنظور
حرب الاهليه بدات في اواخر اربعينيات
القرن الماضي
جزء منها
[تصفيق]
انه رغم كوني ثقافتها جزءا من الثقافه
الصينيه فهذا لا يعني انها جزء من جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الى شطرين لا يجروا احدهما على مهاجمه
الاخر ووضعت العلاقات في اطار معادله
المحصله الصفريه فعندما يفوز طرف تكون
الخساره على الطرف الاخر حتميه
وتر الصين
منهما لا يمكن ان تلحق الضررا بالاخرى دون
ان تضر بنفسها على صعيد التجاره
اما سياسيا فما تزلان في حاله حرب منذ عام
تسعه واربعين
الدول
مرحله
جمهوريه الصين الوطنيه في تايوان من الامم
المتحده
هذا الصوت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من الاعماق بان العالم كله قد خذلنا لقد
قرر اوفق حلفائنا انه لم يعد يعترف بنا
وقرر ان يقيم علاقه مع الطرف الاخر كانت
مرحله تميزت بالتقلب الشديد وقد صاح البعض
قائلين ان تايوان ستغرق وقد ارتفنا نحن
الطلبه الجامعيين حول شعبنا وقلنا لن نقرا
بالضروره
[موسيقى]
ليس للولايات المتحده سفاره في تايوان
رسميا بها وبدلا من ذلك انشات هناك عام 79
المعهد الامريكي
[موسيقى]
من السفراء كنت الثالث عشر واخذ الرئيس
ريجن يتحقق من بطاقات التعريف هنا السفيره
لادا تشيلي والتقطت له صوره معه
انت ذاهب الى تايون اود ان اتحدث اليك
اريد منك ان تتذكر شيئا واحدا وهو انني
احبها هؤلاء الناس تلك هي التعليمات التي
اوعذبها الي للمدير
اما اقتصادها فكانت تغلب عليه الاعداد
الضخمه من العاملين ولم تكن لديها قوه
عسكريه ذات وزن ولم يكن امامها سوى الحد
من اعتمادها على الزراعه والقطاعات محدوده
التقنيه
موت حيوان
الى الموارد الطبيعيه وهي بلد صغير جدا
على مستوى العالم تعزه الى شعبها المتعلم
ومثابته في العمل
والهندسه على مدى سنوات طويله جدا
الماضي
كامله من خارج الجامعات الراقيات جامعه
تايوان الوطنيه
لذا قلت لرئيس الحكومه سون انني ارى انه
لابد من نهضه في مجال اشباه الموصلات
بتايوان والا فلن تتحقق اهداف تايوان في
قطاع التكنولوجيا متقدمه
التايوانيه نفسها وادرك رئيس الحكومه سون
ان مصير الجزيره كان على المحاك فاستعان
بالتعوانيين في الخارج لارسال اسس قطاع
اشباح موصلات كان من افضل والمع
التايوانيين الدكتور بانوان عالم الهندسه
الذي كان يعمل في الولايات المتحده وقد
عاد الى التايوان في مطلع سبعينيات القرن
الماضي وعقد اجتماع طوارئ مع كبار
المسؤولين الحكوميين للتخطيط لمستقبل
البلاد
[موسيقى]
كبار المسؤولين على مائده افطار متواضع
جدا حيث خرجوا بفكره طيبه
وهي اعداد مقترح بهذا الخصوص
بعضها عند الدكتور بان في فندق جراند بضعه
ايام عد خلالها هذا المقترح المبتكر
راى بان ان التقدم التكنولوجيه
والاقتصاديه السريعه وحده يمكن تايون من
التسابي بمفردها للصين وان عليها التحول
من الصناعات المعتمده على اعداد كبيره من
العاملين الى التكنولوجيا المتقدمه
المهندسين التايوانيين الشبان الى
الولايات المتحده لدراسه التكنولوجيا
اشباه الموصلات ثم نقل تلك المعرفه الى
تايوان
ينتج عن تلك الخطه قطاع صناعي كبير في
المتكامله في الولايات المتحده وهي
الراعيده في التكنولوجيا وصناعاتها ومن
اجل خوض هذا المجال فان التعلم من البلد
الرائد فيه كان خير الوسائل واسرعها
لتحقيق ذلك الغرض
[موسيقى]
تكنولوجيا قديمه مقابل ثلاث ملايين ونصف
مليون دولار
اصدار
افضل شركه في الولايات المتحده في مجال
الدائره المتكامله الحصول على رخصه ليس
بالضروره افضل وسيله في مجال التكنولوجيا
افضل وسيله كانت تتمثل باستئجار المدرس
الذي يمكن ان يعلمك تلك التكنولوجيا
واعتقد ان شركه ار سي هي حق المعلم القديم
[موسيقى]
لم تكن اشباه الموصلات حين ذاك مالوفه
وكانت مشاريع شبيهه قد فشلت في كندا
والمملكه المتحده خاض الرئيس السوري معركه
ضد معارض مشروع اشباه الموصلات الذين
اتهموا قاده التايوان بالمقامره بملايين
الدولارات في مشروع لم تثبت جدوه بعد قال
الجميع ان هذه الاموال ينبغي ان تنفق في
مشروع يحقق مردودا عاجلا لا على تكنولوجيا
طوي على مجازفه وفي مؤتمر صحفي كبير ضرب
رئيس الوزراء سونج بقبضته على الطاوله وان
لم يقر هذا المشروع فساستقيل جازف بمنصبه
امام المراسلين
تواجد التايوان في المكان والوقت
المناسبين فبينما كان المهندس هنا
التايوانيون يتعلمون عن اشباه الموصلات من
عرسي ايه كنسيف جوبس والسيف وزنك في
كاليفورنيا يوشكاني على اطلاق ثوره
فارقه ونقطه تحول فخلال عشر سنوات احدث
تشباه الموصلات ثوره في عالم الكمبيوترات
الشخصيه وحول التايون الى معقل
للتكنولوجيا المتقدمه
بلده فيشعر بفخر كبير
على العمل
حار اس اي نوماس »
في مجال اشباه الموصلات كان الناس ينظرون
اليك كواحد من الابطال
دورا كبيرا فقد اقتنع المهندسون
التايوانيون الذين درسوا في الجامعات
الامريكيه كابرستون واستانفورد بان يهجر
وظائفهم المجزيه ويعود الى تايوان
لدى مؤسسات الكبرى في الولايات المتحده
ولم يرغب كثير منهم بالعوده الى تايوان
لذا عقدت الحكومه التايوانيه في
الثمانينات عده ندوات في الولايات المتحده
لاقناع هؤلاء بالعوده الى بلادهم
عادت الى تايوان شخصيات بارزه
الذي غادر شركه التكساس
يتراس شركه تي اس ام سي وسرعان ما ترك
مهندسون تايوانيون مناصبهم في امريكا
وعادوا الى بلادهم يعزى هذا الى انهم
استشعر فرصه نادره وكذلك الى ولائهم
لتايوان
همم
تمت فرصه لكي ترقص مؤسسه تطبق من خلالها
تلك افكار
القرن الماضي الى البلاد
فرصه لكي يكونوا من رواد ذلك القطاع الذي
كان اخذا في التبلورر
بافكاركم والنداء
فرصه ان يحدث فرقا بلوي يحقق افضل مما
حققوه في الولايات المتحده وعليه فقد عاد
كثير منهم واستقروا هنا
في عهد الرئيس الامريكي
الموصلات بالتزامن مع شروع الصين الشعبيه
فيها ثم تفوقوا عليها
لقد جلبوا معهم الخبره والعلاقات والنفوذ
من وادي السيليكون والواقع انه وادي
السيليكون القاب ثقاله
المعرفه بينهما بثلاثه
يعتمد تطوير اشباه الموصلات على اخر ما
توصلت اليه العلوم ما يضع انتاج الرقائق
الدقيقه خارج نطاق وقدره الصناعات الاخرى
في الماضي
اما في عام 97 فقد تحولنا الى انشائي
منظومه من الرقائق متناهيه الصغار وهو ما
يشبه بناء مدينه اما اليوم
بوابه الرقميه الكترونيه وتصميم شيء كهذا
اشبه بتصميم مدينه كبرتينو في كاليفورنيا
ولكم من تتصور ضخامه عمليه التصميم هذا
[موسيقى]
رخصه تكنولوجيا المعالجه من شركه ار سي
وعدت بها الى تايوان حيث صنعوا الرقائق
لكنها كانت بحاجه في الواقع الى اشخاص من
امثال موريس
القطاع وكيفيه بيع منتجاته هناك شركات لم
تستمر لانها لم تنجح في تسويق نفسها
عالميا ضمن هذا القطاع
ودي اي سي
الالمانيه والفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
قفز التايوان من تصدير الاناناس الى انتاج
اشباه الموصلات خلال اقل من عقدين
بقوه تسنده صناعه اشباه الموصلات
في الولايات المتحده بعد اذن اخذت تدريجيا
ادريس
كتابا اكاديميا
خلال التسعينيات القرن الماضي برزت شركات
تايوانيه كاتي اس ام سي باعتبارها شركات
رقائق الكترونيه وصنعت رقائق دقيقه لحساب
شركات اخرى مغيره النمط القديمه المتمثله
في تصنيع كل شيء تحت سقف واحد
[موسيقى]
ث
الباهظه لانتاج رقائق الدوائر الدقيقه
الدولار
[موسيقى]
مبيعات تي اس ام سي وحدها تفوق اليوم قطاع
الزراعه الذي كانت تايوان تعتمد عليه قبل
ربع قرن برمته صناعه الرقائق الدقيقه
المزدهره في تايوان صدرت الى مختلف ارجاء
العالم وفجاه ادرك العالم ذلك
وبحلول منتصف التسعينيات بنت تايوان درعا
من السيليكون الذي سرعان ما تعرض للاختبار
[موسيقى]
كان على راس الثوره التكنولوجيه في تايوان
رئيس تانجوي
وكثير من قاده التايوان تلقى لي دراسات
العليا في الولايات المتحده وفي عام 95
طلب تاشيره لزياره خاصه الى الولايات
المتحده لالقاء كلمه في مؤتمر عقدته جامعه
كورنيل لخريجي جامعه السابقين الصين رات
في تلك زياره اجراءا رسميا يفتح الباب
لعلاقات الرفيعه المستوى
فاعترضت عليها بشده وبعد اخذ ورد منحت
السلطات الامريكيه الرئيس تاشيره زياره
ردت الصين بغضب
تلفزيون الصيني تقرير عن المناوره
وفي اوجد توتر اراده الولايات المتحده
بارسال قوات على حاملتي طائرات الى
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
على ان تكون طريقه تحقيق مبدا الصين واحده
طريقه سلميه لكننا لم نرى انما حدثك ناسيا
بل كان ضغطا عسكريا
اردنا ان نحتاج لدى حكومه الصين باشد
الطرق صرامه
ارسال قواتنا على حاملي طائرات الى
المنطقه
يوتيوب
لا اعتقد ذلك كنا نعلم ان المساله كانت
نفسيه بالكامله فقد كانت الصين تريد
ممارسه الضغط النفسي على تايوان ذلك كان
هدفهم الاول من اطلاق الصواريخ كل ما كانت
الصين تعتزمه واستخدام الحرب النفسيه وليس
الاستيلاء على تايوان وقد كنا مستعدين
ايضا للتصدي للغزل
اكثر
البحري في العالم كله فاحدث نقصا في
منتجات تكنولوجيا المعلومات وقد اقلق ذلك
مزيدا من الدول تحتاجت واستنكرت وغضبت
تلك التدريبات العسكريه قبل الموعد الذي
كان متوقعا
بتاع البيتبول
رسمت الازمه التي ثارت عام 96 على ما
تتحول فقد وفر درع السيليكون لتاي وانقدرا
من الحمايه زاد على اثر الحضور العسكري
الامريكي وذلك لان كل من الصين وتايوان قد
ادركت انه اذا ما هجمت احداهما الاخرى
فستدمر كلتاهما
[موسيقى]
يتركز معقلوا انتاج الرقائق الدقيقه في
العالم في مجمع شينجو للعلوم الذي انشا
عام 80 في سن الريفيه التي كانت قد اشتهرت
باسم مزرعه
الارزات والمرافق العلميه في تايوان بتلك
المتعلقه باجراء الابحاث في الجامعات كما
فكرت في انشاء مجمع ان العلوم بجوار
جامعتينغ هو بدا التنفي
واعتقد ان لهذا المجمع اهميه جوهريه لان
القائمين على ابحاث التكنولوجيا الصناعه
يفكرون في تكنولوجيا ار سي 8 وكيف ستصبح
كيان تجاريا لذا فقط
التي يمكن ان تقصدها التكنولوجيا
وهي شركه يونايتد ماكرون يو ام سي قد في
مجمع العلوم وهكذا فقد اصبح مجمع العلوم
هو المكان الذي استوعب العلماء العائدين
من الولايات المتحده
بكبسه زر وخلافه للنفط لا يمكن تحويل مسار
امدادات الرقائق الدقيقه ولا تلبيه الطلب
عليها من مصادر بديله ولا يمكن استغلال
الاحتياطيات
[موسيقى]
هو ان يشنه هجوم ارهابي او تشن غاره جويه
على مجمع مثل مجمع علوم التكنولوجيا
او 20 معمل في مكان مكشوف
كويس
صناعات التي تعتمد
يستغرق سنوات
[موسيقى]
فيسبوك
كارثه عليهما معا فضلا عن الكلفه الماديه
والبشريه للمجابهه العسكريه التي يمكن ان
تدمر اقتصاد البلدين ليس اقتصاده تايوان
فقط بالاقتصاد الصيني ايضا يدرك البلدان
ذلك تماما وهذا يعد راضي عن صارما عن
اتخاذ اجراء عسكري لكن هذا لا يعد راضي عن
قاطعا صحيح انه يدقون خسى الخطر لكنه لا
يجعل وقوعه مستحيلا لذا من الممكن ان تحدث
ظروف سياسيه تقنع الصين او تايوان بضخامه
الاخطار السياسيه فتكون مستعده لتحمل
التكلفه الاقتصاديه واتبعات الاخرى لذلك
في وادي درش بالنسبه لقدره دول اخرى على
ابتكار درعي سيليكون كستراتيجيه دفاعيه
اقول ان هذه مساله سياسه خارجيه عليا حيث
تجعل دوله ما نفسها مهمه اقتصاديا للعالم
ثم تبرهن للعالم على ذلك مباحه ما الذي
سيحدث اذا ما هوجمت او اذيت وكم سيؤثر ذلك
على العالم ككل اعتقد ان تلك وسيله فعاله
جدا في حسن اداره شؤون الدوله
تعميق التكامل بين سلاسل التوريد قد تتمخض
عنه مشاريع مشتركه توسع دائره الدرع
السيليكون
هنا حيث ارباب العمل وحيث حريه تبادل
الافكار
لذا اعتقد ان تلك القوه الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه سيكون لها تاثير كبير على
البرامج السياسيه
يحل محله ابنه الذي تعلم في السنفورد
ويبني علاقه مع الصين وينشئ مصانع هنا
وهناك تنتج سلع عن استهلاكيه ويعبر عما
يريد قوله بوضوح بالانجليزيه فهل هو
بكفاءه ابيه سوف نرى
حدوث تكامل سياسي بين تايوان
كبرى نحو التعاون الاقتصاديه حتى على غرار
التعاون الاقتصادي بين دول الاتحاد
الاوروبيين من احتمال افراغ بلادهم من
قدراتها الاقتصاديه بنقل مصانعها الى
الصين ومن فقدان كل تلك الوظائف في مجال
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه وهذا شبيه بما نسمعه
تمام لكن تايون تتحكم ربما في سبعين
بالمئه من تكنولوجيا المعلومات الصينيه
بالفعل
لقد تجاوز التاثير استراتيجيه اشباه
الموصلات التايوانيه النمو الاقتصاديه الى
ابعاد اخرى ربما لم يتوقعها من يطلقها في
الايام الحاليه لتايوان
انتشرت تايوان عالميا لدرجه ان اي ضربه
فيها تؤثر في امدادات اشباه الموصلات
والكمبيوترات على مستوى العالم
هزه من هذا القبيل وقعت في سبتمبر عام 99
حين ضرب زلزال شديد وسط تايوان واودى
بحياه اكثر من 2000 شخص كما قطع الكهرباء
عن المصانع في مجمع شينجو للعلوم سته ايام
ما عرق السلسله امدادات الالكترونيه
عالميا
اما في بور ستريت فقد شهدت اسهم شركات
التكنولوجيا قد الكمبيوتر
حادا خشيه نقص اجزاء التركيب فتنبه العالم
لاول مره الى اهميه التايوان كحلقه في
سلسله التوريد العالميه
اكثر من اي وقت مضى على اشباه الموصلات
بدون نهايه
ورزان
[موسيقى]
لم تكن سهله
حتى وقت قريب كان على الطائرات ان تتوقف
في هونج كونج ثم تتابع طيرانها الى شنغهاي
وبعد تحسن العلاقات بين الطرفين سيرت
رحلات مباشره بطائرات مستاجره ويتوقع في
نهايه المطاف تسير رحلات تجاريه بلا توقف
يجعلها تقلق على امنها وهي تسلك طريقا
وسطا بين القلق على امرها وبين سياستها
الاقتصاديه
على الامن وعلى السياسه وان على اساس يعني
يتخفف من ذلك
القائمون على صناعه اشباه الموصلات في
تايوان يرون ان عليه من يقيم مراكز في
الصين اكبر مستهلك لاشباه الموصلات الا ان
سرعه الاعمال التجاريه اصطدمت باكراهات
السياسه
وتلعسكريه للاستيلاء على الاراضي وقد
اعلنت الصين انها لن تستخدم
القوه تايوان وفي الوقت ذاته هي اكبر
مستهلك للنمو في العالم وما لم نستفيد
منها فسنتخلف عن غيرنا
هناك كان عليها الاستفاده من البنيه
التحتيه وانخفاض كلفه العماله في الصين كي
تتمكن من تلبيه احتياجات الزبائنها حول
العالم
في عام 2006 قاضت الحكومه التايوانيه
روبرتساو رئيس شركه يونايتد مايكرو
الكترونيكس ثاني اكبر مصانع الرقائق في
العالم لان شركته استثمرت في شركه صينيه
كان ضمن الفريق المؤسسي لشركه ار سي اي
مواجهه عقوبه بالسجن تصل الى خمس سنوات في
حالي دانته لكنه بريا من التهمه حكومه
الشويبن السابقه المؤيده للاستقلال كانت
تعتبر ان كبار مسؤولي شركات اشباه
الموصلات التايوانيين الذين استثمر في
الصين لاعبوا لعبه خاسره
الاقتصاديه على الاعتبارات الاخرى
الا انهم في الواقع يعرضون البنيه
السياسيه لتايوان وانها القويه ايضا للخطر
لانه كل ما توثقت العلاقه الاقتصاديه مع
الصين كلما حلت هويه تايوان
التكنولوجيا في صنع اسلحه الدفاعيه
تستخدمها ضد الولايات المتحده ونحن في
تايوان نشعر بقلق مماثل اضف الى اننا نريد
ان نحافظ على التفوقنا في تطوير الصناعه
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه لدينا
لعبه ياسين
في تايوان ومن خلالها تتاح لنا الفرصه
للاختيار بين حمايه القطاع التكنولوجيا
المتقدمه في بلادنا والا نعمل مع الصين او
ان نتقاسم مع الصين ما توصلنا اليه من
تكنولوجيا اي هما افضل لامي تايوان
[موسيقى]
الموالي للصين رئيسا لتايوان وقد سار عمان
الى تخفيف القيود على استثمارات
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه في الصين وسماح
بمزيد من تصنيع اشباه الموصلات المتقدمه
بعدما كان ذلك محظورا في ظل حكومه تشن وقد
قال منتقد اما ان اجراءاته تضعف درع
السيليكون في تايوان
اغنيه
بين المشاكل التي تواجه الصين
امم افريقيا
بدا الجميع
على قدم المساواه من حيث السياده ما مكنهم
من الماضي نحو الاتحاد اما في حاله الصين
والتايوان فلا توجد تلك المساواه
وبالتاليف المهمه صعبه
تايوان في التعامل مع مختلف الدول كالهندي
واليابان وفي الانخراط اكثر فاكثر في
التكنولوجيا بل والحصول على تكنولوجيا
جديده من اليابان او الولايات المتحده
علينا ان ننجز هذا النوع من التكامل
مستقبلا ونتوصل الى نتيجه النهائيه
بالوسائل الديمقراطيه يجب حل المسائل بطرق
سلميه ليس قصرا او بوسيله عسكريه لا نريد
من الصين دوله ذات سياده لكن علينا على
الاقل ان اجري هذا النوع من المبادلات
والمفاوضات على اساس من المساواه
او الصين
ارى ان هذا نموذج جيد لكن هناك مشكله اخرى
وهي ان المساله لا تنحصر في المصالح
الاقتصاديه المشتركه بل تتعداها الى
الشعور بالقيم المشتركه الواحد التي قام
عليها الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي تشكل بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
عن العالم بفعل ما تقوم به جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه لعزله عن المؤسسات الدوليه
والاقتصاد العالمي ومع ذلك فلهذا البلد
اقتصاد من اكثر الاقتصادات والديمقراطيات
حيويه في العالم
تكنولوجيا المعلومات
لما كان لا يتعاون بين الطرفين في مجله
اخرى ان يتسع بالمقدار نفسه او ان يبلغ
العمق
الشركات الاجنبيه للعمل بلا قيود تذكر
والاستثمار والمساعده واطلاع التايوانين
على معارفها قادمات ارسنال وفي لبس
وما يؤدي الى بدء النشاط ليس بالحواجز
والجدران تبني بلاده ولو فعلت تايوان ذلك
لما تمكنت من تحقيق هذا النمو
جاء نتيجته لسياسه الانفتاح
سمحت بتدفق المعلومات والمعارف والخبراء
بحريه الى تايوان
والمشكله التي تواجه السياسه اليوم هي
جنون الارتياب هم يخشون فقدان قاعدتهم
الاقتصاديه في حين ان فتح الابواب وتعميق
القدرات هو السبيل لتحسين حظوظ الجميع
فلم يكن هناك ما يكفي من الناطقين
بالصينيه لاصال التكنولوجيا اليها كما كان
لصناعه الرقائق الالكترونيه في تايوان
اكثر مهم في تلك المنطقه من العالم برمتها
اذ لم تكن موجوده هناك قبل ثلاثين سنه
[موسيقى]